ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM THE
SERGEANT AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS THE CLERK WILL
CALL THE ROLL. AGUIAR-CURRY
ARAMBULA BAUER-KAHAN BERMAN
BIGELOW BLOOM BOERNER HORVATH.
BONTA BRO BURKE CALDERON
CARRILLO CERVANTES CHAU CHEN
DAVID CHIU CHOI KANSEN CHU
COOLEY COOPER CUNNINGHAM DALLY
DALY DEEP EGGMAN FLORA FONG
FRAZIER FRIEDMAN GABRIEL
GALLAGHER CRISTINA GARCIA
EDUARDO GARCIA. GIPSON GLORIA
GONZALEZ GRAY GRAYSON HOLDEN
IRWIN JONES SAWYER. CHOLERA
KAMLAGER KILEY LACKEY LEVINE
LIMON LOW MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS
MAYES MCCARTY MEDINA MELENDEZ
MULLIN MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN
OBERNOLTE O'DONNELL PATTERSON
PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK QUIRK SILVA
RAMOS RAMOS THREE OF US ROBERT
RIVAS RODRIGUEZ RUBIO SALAS
SANTIAGO SMITH. STONE TING
VOEPEL WALDRON WEBER WICKS WOOD
MISTER SPEAKER
. MEMBERS. A
QUORUM IS PRESENT WE ASK OUR
GUESTS AND VISITORS IN THE REAR
OF THE CHAMBER AND IN THE
GALLERY TO PLEASE STAND FOR THE
PRAYER TODAY'S PRAYER WILL BE
OFFERED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
HOLDEN. ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOLDEN.
SEE. GOOD MORNING BUT AS PRIDE.
ONLY FATHER WE GIVE YOU HONOR
AND GLORY THIS MORNING AS
REMEMBER THE AMAZING LEGACY OF
THE REVEREND DOCTOR MARTIN
LUTHER KING JUNIOR. HIS LIFE
WAS ONE OF SACRIFICE COURAGE
COMPASSION AND LOVE IT IS A
TESTAMENT TO YOUR GREATNESS.
LORD BY YOUR WILL YOU HAD A
PLAN FOR DR KING. A BRAND NEW
PLAN THE HEARTS AND MINDS WOULD
BE TRANSFORMED THROUGH LOVE AND
NON VIOLENCE THE TOOLS OF YOUR
CHOOSING FOR DOCTOR KING TO BE
SEEN. AS INSTRUMENT FOR CHANGE
IN THE WORLD. LIKEWISE LORD
HONE OUR VISION THAT WE SEE
CLEARLY YOUR PLAN FOR OUR LIVES
THAT YOUR WILL BE DONE. AS
SCRIPTURE REMINDS US WE ARE HIS
WORKMANSHIP CREATED IN CHRIST
JESUS FOR GOOD WORKS WHICH GOD
PREPARED BEFOREHAND THAT WE
SHOULD WALK IN THEM. WE PRAY
THIS MORNING FATHER MOVED BY
YOUR SPIRIT. THAT WE REVEAL
YOUR WORKMANSHIP AND US AS WE
WALK IN LOVE AND GOOD WORKS DR
KING SO OBEDIENTLY DID.
CONTINUE TO DO A GOOD WORK
THROUGH THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS AND
THE ENTIRE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSEMBLY. BR STRONG TOWER. LET
US CONTINUE TO BE EFFECTIVE AND
DECISIVE. MAYBE RUN AND NOT BE
WEARY. A MAN. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER HOLDEN WE ASK
OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS TO
REMAIN STANDING AND JOIN US FOR
THE FLAG SALUTE PLEASE JOIN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JONES SAWYER AS
HE LEADS US IN THE PLEDGE TO
RIGHT HAND OVER YOUR HEART
READY BEGIN I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE
TO THE FLAG OF THE UNITED
STATES OF AMERICA AND TO THE
REPUBLIC FOR WHICH IT STANDS
ONE NATION UNDER GOD
INDIVISIBLE WITH LIBERTY. AND
JUSTICE FOR ALL. THANK YOU YOU
MAY BE SEATED. MOVING TO THE
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL ASSEMBLY CHAMBER
SACRAMENTO WEDNESDAY JANUARY
EIGHTH TWENTY TWENTY THE
ASSEMBLY MET AT SEVEN AM ON
WILL PROCEED AND GARCIA
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FIFTIETH
DISTRICT PRESIDING SIR CALDERON
MOVES MISTER GALLAGHER SECONDS
AT THE READING OF THE PREVIOUS
DAY'S JOURNAL BE DISPENSED
WITH. PRESENTATIONS OF
PETITIONS THERE ARE NONE. IN
THE INTRODUCTION AND REFERENCE
TO BILLS WILL BE DEFERRED
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
DEEMED ADOPTED. MESSAGES FROM
THE GOVERNOR THERE ARE NONE
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE THERE
ARE NONE. MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS TODAY'S ABSENCES%
FOR LEGISLATIVE BUSINESS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER EDUARDO GARCIA
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAYES FOR
PERSONAL BUSINESS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER DEEP. FOR ILLNESSES
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CERVANTES GRAY
AND LEVINE. AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
EGGMAN FOR DEATH IN THE FAMILY.
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY
RULE ONE EIGHTEEN A TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHOI AND SOMEONE
AND WALDRON TO HAVE GUESTS AND
PHOTOGRAPHERS ON THE FLOOR
TODAY WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER ALSO REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY FIVE POINT
FIVE TO ALLOW SOMETHING MEMBERS
CHOI MEDINA COUNTY.
PETRIE-NORRIS AND WEBER TO
SPEAK ON IN GERMANY MEMORY
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY
RULE NINETY SIX WITHDRAWAL AB
THREE TWENTY THREE DAILY FOR
THE BUDGET COMMITTEE IN ORDER
THE BILL. BACK TO THIRD READING
FILE. I'M READING THE WRONG ONE
AND SPEAKER I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY ONE
EIGHTY NAY TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY TO
HAVE GUESTS AND PHOTOGRAPHERS
ON THE FLOOR AND FOR THE
SPEAKER TO HAVE A PHOTOGRAPHER
IN THE GALLERY WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLYRULE FORTY FIVE POINT FIVE
ALLOW ASSEMBLY MEMBERS JONES
SAWYER SALAS GIPSON AND ABLE TO
SPEAK ON A GERMAN MEMORY TODAY
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER AT THE REQUEST OF THE
AUTHORS PLEASE MOVE THE
FOLLOWING BILLS INACTIVE FILE
ITEM ONE TWENTY SIX EIGHT.
SEVEN SIX FOUR BONTA AN ITEM
ONE TWENTY SEVEN AB TWO
SEVENTEEN BURKE. WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER. MEMBERS WE HAVE GUESTS
WITH US IN THE ASSEMBLY TODAY.
THIS AGUIAR-CURRY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GUEST
INTRODUCTION. THANK YOU MS
SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE TODAY TO
RECOGNIZE A SIGNIFICANT
DEPARTURE FROM THE ASSEMBLY
FAMILY. DEBBIE MICHAEL IS
STARTING THE NEXT CHAPTER OF
HER CAREER AT EAST BAY
MUNICIPAL UTILITY DISTRICT
AFTER FOURTEEN YEARS IN THE
ASSEMBLY AND ELEVEN YEARS ON
THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE
SEVEN AS A CHIEF CONSULTANT.
SHE STARTED OUT AS A LEDGE AID
WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER HELEN
THOMPSON AND WORK WITH OUR
FORMER COLLEAGUES LOS WALK IN A
REGULAR SENIOR BEFORE SPENDING
FOUR YEARS OF THE LEAGUE OF
CITIES. DEBBIE HAS BECOME A
WELL RESPECTED AND TRUSTED
EXPERT AND ADVISOR ON LOCAL
LAND USE AND HAS BEEN MY ROCK
WELL I'VE HAD THE HONOR TO BE
THE CHAIR OF LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
SHE IS TRULY AMAZING.
PROFESSIONAL AND A WONDERFUL
PERSON. SHE DOES THIS WITH THIS
JOB THE WAY COMMITTEE
CONSULTANT SHOULD ALWAYS
PROTECT THE INTERESTS OF THE
COMMITTEE AND THE ASSEMBLY WAS
SEEKING TO HELP MEMBERS
ACCOMPLISH AS MET MUCH OF THE
GOAL AS POSSIBLE WITH BILLS
BEFORE THE COMMITTEE. DEBBIE
TODAY'S ACCOMPANIED IN THE
GALLERY BY HER HUSBAND PEDRO
SON CHARLIE DAUGHTER CLEO AND
FATHER ROY. I HOPE YOU WILL ALL
JOIN ME IN WISHING DEBBIE AND
HER FAMILY THE BEST AND I'M
HAPPY SHE WILL STILL BE IN
LOCAL GOVERNMENT POLICY SO WE
CAN CONTINUE TO SEE HER FROM
TIME TO TIME. DEBBIE MICHAEL.
THANK YOU I'M GONNA MISS YOU.
CONGRATULATIONS
. THANK YOU MISS
MICHAEL FOR YOUR SERVICE TO OUR
BODY. MISTER GIBSON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
INTRODUCTION. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS OF I
RISE TODAY BECAUSE I HAVE SOME
SPECIAL GUESTS WITH ME IN THE
CAPITAL THE SEED IN THE GALLERY
THESE INDIVIDUALS THAT HAS
WORKED OVER- ROUND THE CLOCK
FOR THE PEOPLE OF THE SIXTY
FOURTH ASSEMBLY DISTRICT- TODAY
IS OUR OUR STAFF RETREAT OUR
TEAM RETREAT AND I'M HAPPY TO
HAVE- MY DISTRICT TEAM WITH
ROUTE WHICH BUDGET TEAM ANY
GALLERY PLEASE STAND MEMBERS
PLEASE GIVE ABOUT APPLAUSE. TO
THE DESERT CHAMBER THE SIXTY
FOURTH FAMILY. WELCOME TO ALL
OF OUR GUESTS TODAY. MOVING TO
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE.
SECOND READING THE CLERK WILL
READ S A LEGAL NINE OH FOR ALL
BILLS HAVE BEEN DEEMED READ AND
AMENDMENTS ADOPTED GOVERNOR'S
VETOES FILE ITEMS TWO THROUGH
ONE EIGHTEEN SHALL BE CONTINUED
FILE ITEMS ON RECONSIDERATION
NUMBERS ONE NINETEEN THROUGH
ONE TWENTY THREE. OUR
CONTINUED. MOVING TO THE
ASSEMBLY THIRD READING FILE
.
FILE ITEMS ONE TWENTY FOUR
THROUGH ONE TWENTY TWO EIGHT
TWENTY ONE TWENTY EIGHT WILL BE
ASCERTAINED MOVING TO FILE ITEM
ONE TWENTY NINE ACR ONE FORTY
SIX THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
ONE FORTY SIX BY FAMILY MEMBER
WEBER AND OTHERS RELATIVE TO
THE REVEREND DOCTOR MARTIN
LUTHER KING JUNIOR DOCTOR WEBER
YOU MAY OPEN ON THE RESOLUTION
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING- AND-
MADAM SPEAKER IN MEMBERS TODAY
I RISE UP ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE BLACK
CAUCUS TO PRESENT YOU ACR- ONE
FORTY SIX TO COMMEMORATE THE
LIFE AND LEGACY OF DR MARTIN
LUTHER KING. I WANT TO THANK
ALL THE MEMBERS WHO ATTENDED
YESTERDAY'S BREAKFAST AND ARE
YOU WERE INSPIRED BY A SPEAKER
IN BY THE ACTIVITIES THAT OCCUR.
CALIFORNIA SHOULD BE PROUD THAT
IT WAS THE FIRST STATE TO THE
BRIGHT THE LIFE OF DR KING. WE
ARE EQUALLY PROUD THAT THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE BLACK
CAUCUS AT THAT TIME. ADVOCATING
FOR COMMEMORATIVE HOLIDAY THAT
WAS SPREAD THROUGHOUT THE
UNITED STATES. IT TOOK THREE
ATTEMPTS TO GET IT DONE BUT
THEY GOT IT DONE. AND THAT'S
ONE THING THAT THE AFRICAN
AMERICAN COMMUNITY KNOWS BEST
IS PERSISTENCE. WE KNOW THAT IF
WE WANT TO ACCOMPLISH ANYTHING
THERE WILL BE OPPOSITION AND WE
REQUIRE THE BEST OF US TO
ACCOMPLISH IT. WE ARE CURRENTLY
LIVING IN UNSETTLING TIMES AND
PERSISTENT AND JUSTICE HAS NOT
BEEN RESOLVED AND THERE IS A
REVIVAL OF OLD HATREDS. THAT WE
THOUGHT LONG HAD BEEN TO PUT TO
REST. ONCE AGAIN IS NOT ENOUGH
TO SIMPLY SAY DR KING'S LEGACY
IS WHAT IT IS BUT HOW MUCH WE
MEAN IT MEANS TO ALL OF US. THE
RESOLUTION TODAY CHRONICLES DR
KING'S LIFE IN THIS STRUGGLE IN
THIS COUNTRY AS AN ORDINARY
CITIZEN. TO DO EXTRAORDINARY
WORK. AND WE LIVE IN HIS LEGACY
TODAY AS WE MOVE FORWARD. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE FOR ACR ONE FORTY SIX.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WEBER. THIS
RACE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON THIS
MATTER. THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
I RISE TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S CAUCUS IN
SUPPORT OF A C. R. ONE FORTY
SIX WHICH HONORS THE LATE
REVEREND DOCTOR MARTIN LUTHER
KING JUNIOR. EVERY YEAR AS WE
CELEBRATE THIS GREAT MAN WHO
ACCOMPLISHED SO MUCH IN HIS
UNFORTUNATELY ABBREVIATED LIFE
A WORD THAT ALWAYS COMES TO
MIND IS SERVICE. SERVICE I'M
SURE IS NOT A FOREIGN WORD TO
ANYBODY IN THIS ROOM. WE ALL
MADE THE DECISION TO RUN FOR
OFFICE IN ORDER TO BETTER SERVE
OUR COMMUNITIES. BUT SERVICE
ISN'T JUST A WORD. I BELIEVE WE
STILL HAVE A LOT OF WORK TO
LEARN WE HAVE A LOT TO LEARN
FROM THE WAY DR KING
EXEMPLIFIED SERVICE. FOR HIM
SERVICE WAS A NECESSITY. NOT
BASED ON EGO OR OR ON RECEIVING
ACCOLADES. IT WAS A LIFE OR
DEATH EVERY DAY DECISION. THIS
WAS EVIDENT BY HIS COURAGE TO
SAY THE THINGS THAT NEEDED TO
BE SAID. NO MATTER HOW
UNPOPULAR. HIS WILLINGNESS TO
BE IN THE PLACES THAT SAW THE
GREATEST INJUSTICE NO MATTER
HOW DANGEROUS. AND HIS
COMPASSION WITH THE PEOPLE WHO
FACE THE GREATEST INEQUITIES.
WHETHER OR NOT THEY LOOK LIKE
HIM. AS WE STEP INTO A NEW
LEGISLATIVE SESSION. I IMPLORE
US ALL TO REMEMBER WHY WE MADE
THE DECISION TO SERVE THE FORTY
MILLION PEOPLE OF THIS GREAT
STATE. AND I HOPE WE TAKE A
PAGE FROM DOCTOR KING'S BOOK.
AND SERVE WITH SIMILAR COURAGE
WILLINGNESS AND COMPASSION. I
HOPE WE ARE ABLE TO SAY THE
TRUTH EVEN WHEN DIFFICULT AND
TO DEMAND JUSTICE EVEN WHEN
DANGEROUS AND TO DEFEND THE
COMMUNITIES ON THE MARGINS OF
SOCIETY. ESPECIALLY WOMEN.
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR LOW INCOME
FAMILIES DISABLED COMMUNITIES
ARE LGBT Q. FRIENDS AND OTHERS.
EVEN WHEN THEY DON'T LOOK LIKE
US FOR THIS REASON I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISS RAST MR
GABRIEL YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON
THIS RESOLUTION. MADAM SPEAKER
I RISE TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE JEWISH
CAUCUS TO HONOR THE REMARKABLE
LIFE AND LEGACY OF DR MARTIN
LUTHER KING JUNIOR. THE JEWISH
CAUCUSES PROUD TO JOIN IN
RECOGNIZING DR KING AS ONE OF
THE GREATEST AMERICANS OF ANY
GENERATION. DR KING IS ALWAYS
OCCUPIED A SPECIAL PLACE IN THE
HEARTS AND MINDS OF AMERICAN
JEWS. FOR MANY IN OUR COMMUNITY
HE PERSONIFIED THE QUEST FOR
FREEDOM HUMAN DIGNITY AND
JUSTICE THAT ARE THE CENTRAL
FOCUS OF JEWISH TRADITION.
INDEED FEW IMAGES INSPIRE S
MUCH EMOTION IN PRIDE IN THE
JEWISH COMMUNITY AS THE ICONIC
IMAGE OF RABBI ABRAHAM JOSHUA
HESCHEL. THE MOST REVERED RABBI
OF HIS GENERATION MARCHING ARM
IN ARM WITH DOCTOR KING ACROSS
THE EDMUND PETTUS BRIDGE IN
MARCH OF NINETEEN SIXTY FIVE.
AFTERWARDS IN WORDS THAT WERE
QUOTED BY PRESIDENT OBAMA HALF
A CENTURY LATER RABBI HESCHEL
REFLECTED THAT WHEN HE WAS
MARCHING WITH DOCTOR KING HE
FELT THAT HIS LEGS WERE PRAYING.
THAT SAME YEAR THE AMERICAN
JEWISH COMMITTEE HONOR DOCTOR
KING WITH HIS PRESTIGIOUS
AMERICAN LIBERTIES BATTALION.
IN RECOGNITION OF HIS EFFORTS
TO ADVANCE CIVIL RIGHTS AND
SOCIAL JUSTICE FOR ALL
AMERICANS. IN BOTH WORD AND
DEED DOCTOR KING WAS ALSO A
GREAT FRIEND AND ALLY TO THE
JEWISH COMMUNITY IN OUR OWN
STRUGGLES. HE SPOKE OUT
POWERFULLY AGAINST ANTI
SEMITISM IN DEFENSE OF THE
STATE OF ISRAEL AND FOR THE
HUMAN RIGHTS OF PERSECUTED JEWS
IN THE SOVIET UNION. DR KING
NOTED THAT A SHARED HISTORY OF
OPPRESSION AND A DEEP UNIVERSAL
COMMITMENT TO JUSTICE BIND OUR
COMMUNITIES. STATING MY PEOPLE
WERE BROUGHT TO AMERICAN
CHAINS. YOUR PEOPLE WERE DRIVEN
HERE TO ESCAPE THE CHANGED
FASHION FOR THEM IN EUROPE. OUR
UNITY IS BORN OF COMMON
STRUGGLE FOR CENTURIES NOT ONLY
TO RID OURSELVES OF BONDAGE BUT
TO MAKE OPPRESSION OF ANY
PEOPLE BY OTHERS ANY
POSSIBILITY. THIS WEEKEND
YOU'RE COMMUNITIES ACROSS
CALIFORNIA WILL HOLD SPECIAL
SERVICES TO DOCTOR TO HONOR
DOCTOR KING OFTENTIMES
PARTNERING WITH OUR MUSLIM AND
CHRISTIAN NEIGHBORS IN
FELLOWSHIP AND UNITY THAT
REFLECTS HIS VISION. TOGETHER
WE WILL TEACH OUR CHILDREN
ABOUT DOCTOR KING'S ENORMOUS
BRAVERY HIS MORAL CLARITY AND
HIS ON FINISH STRUGGLE FOR
JUSTICE. WE WERE REFLECT ON HIS
TREMENDOUS ACCOMPLISHMENTS AND
CRINGE AT HOW MUCH WORK REMAINS
TO TRULY FULFILL HIS DREAM. AND
WE WILL STRIVE TO HONOR HIS
LEGACY BY JOINING HANDS TO
FULFILL HIS VISION OF A MORE
JUST WORLD. IN THAT SPIRIT AND
ON BEHALF OF THE JEWISH CAUCUS
I RESPECTFULLY URGE SUPPORT FOR
THIS RESOLUTION. THANK YOU MR
GABRIEL MISS WALDRON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED IN THIS RESOLUTION.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS. DR MARTIN LUTHER KING
ONCE SAID LIFE'S MOST
PERSISTENT AND URGENT QUESTION
IS WHAT ARE YOU DOING FOR
OTHERS. IN RECOGNITION OF DR
KING'S INCREDIBLE LEGACY OF
SERVICE TO WALL CONGRESS
DESIGNATED THE MARTIN LUTHER
KING JUNIOR FEDERAL HOLIDAY. AS
A NATIONAL DAY OF SERVICE IN
NINETEEN NINETY FOUR. AS WE
HEAD HOME TO OUR DISTRICTS THIS
WEEKEND MY HOPE S THAT WE WILL
ALL SPEND A FEW MINUTES TO
REFLECT. ON THE BRIEF THIS
BRIEF YET IMPORTANT QUESTION.
AN APROPRIATE WAY TO HONOR
DOCTOR KING IS THROUGH SERVICE
AND VOLUNTEERING IN OUR
COMMUNITIES. DR KING DEVOTED
HIS LIFE TO ADVANCING THE
QUALITY SOCIAL JUSTICE AND
ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY FOR ALL.
HE CHALLENGED US TO BUILD A
MORE PERFECT UNION AND TAUGHT
US THAT EVERYONE HAS A ROLE TO
PLAY I REGION I VOTE. THANK YOU
MISS WALDRON MISTER GLORIA YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I RISE THIS MORNING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE LGBT Q. CAUCUS AS
VICE CHAIR IN SUPPORT OF ACR
ONE FORTY SIX WITH APPRECIATION
TO MY GREAT COLLEAGUE FROM SAN
DIEGO. MEMBERS TODAY WE HONOR A
GIANT IN THE LEGACY OF ACTION
IN A SOCIAL JUSTICE DOCTOR
MARTIN KING JUNIOR'S LEGACY
CONTINUES TO LIGHT A PATH FOR
THOSE WHO FIGHT FOR EQUAL NON
DISCRIMINATORY AND IMPARTIAL
AMERICA. NEED COURSE AS ME MY
COLLEAGUES ALREADY NOTED
INSPIRED US TO RISE ABOVE
HATEFUL RHETORIC TO PUSH FOR A
QUALITY AT EVERY TURN EVEN WHEN
IT SEEMED IMPOSSIBLE EVEN WHEN
THE ODDS WERE LONG AND OF
COURSE ON THE TIMES WERE
SUCCESS WAS HAD. AS A COMMUNITY
THAT IS UNDERSTANDING OF THE
DISCRIMINATION THAT CONTINUES
TO THIS DAY NAY THAT EQUITIES
THAT WE IN DOOR WE RECOGNIZE
THE INTERSECTION ALLERGY OF DR
KING'S MOVEMENT THE FACT IT WAS
MORE THAN JUST RACIAL CIVIL
RIGHTS EQUALITY WORKERS RIGHTS
POVERTY ELIMINATION DR KING'S
UNDERSTOOD THE WORLD WAS INTER
CONNECTED. AND AS A COMMUNITY
THAT IS RARELY THE MAJORITY IN
ANY PARTICULAR ROOM WE
APPRECIATE THE ALLIES THAT COME
TO OUR DEFENSE AND RECOGNIZE
THE DOCTOR KING SURROUNDED
HIMSELF WITH ALLIES OF COURSE
IS GREAT WIFE CREDIT SCOTT KING
WAS A LONG A SUPPORTER OF THE
LGBT Q. MOVEMENT CERTAINLY LONG
BEFORE WAS POPULAR. NATURAIS
MUST GO IT MUST BE BAD BAIRD
RUSTIN THEN THE LG Q. MEMBER OF
DR KING'S INNER CIRCLE
EXPRESSES THE SUPPORT THAT WE
KNOW DOCTOR KING WOULD HAVE HAD
FOR FULL LGBT Q. A QUALITY IN
THIS COUNTRY. AND SO WE
APPRECIATE DR KING IS A STRONG
ALLY IT IS MOVEMENT THAT WE
HAVE BENEFITTED FROM AND LET
OUR VOICES IN SUPPORT OF THE
ONGOING WORK THAT IS NEEDED FOR
RACIAL AND ECONOMIC JUSTICE IN
THIS COUNTRY. AND I SPEAK OUT
ALSO LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE AS A
MEMBER OF THE P. I. CAUCUS THAT
WE TO STAY IN SOLIDARITY WITH
OF OUR COLLEAGUE FROM SAN DIEGO
SUPPORT OF A C. R. WHAT FORTY
SIX. SO WITH THE PRE ASIAN OPEN
RESPECT THAT ALL OF US BECAUSE
OF THIS WEEKEND A. KNOWLEDGE
AND CELEBRATE THE LIFE OF DR
KING. THANK. COURAGE ARE
CALLING IN CONSTITUENTS TO
CONTINUE THE WORK OF JUSTICE IN
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU. THANK
GLORIA IS YOUR COOLEY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. COLLEAGUES I WISH
TO RISE IN HONOR OF MARTIN
LUTHER KING THEM KING ON THIS
DAY- AND I WANT TO BRING TO YOU
SOME REFLECTIONS OF OTHER
PEOPLE IN AMERICAN HISTORY
PEOPLE ACTUALLY DID KNOW MARTIN
LUTHER KING. BUT WHO SAID
NATION THAT ARE. VERY APROPOS
ON THIS DAY. IN THE EARLY
NINETEEN HUNDREDS THERE IS A
YOUNG MAN MATTHEW HENSON.
MATTHEW HENSON WENT TO THE
NORTH POLE WITH WITH COMMODORE
PERRY HE WAS AN AFRICAN
AMERICAN EXPLORER. AND MATTHEW
HENSON HAD INTERESTING VIEWS
ABOUT LIFE THAT ARE VERY
RELEVANT TO DOCTOR KING. HE
SAID GREAT IDEALS OF THE GLORY
OF MAN ALONE. NORTHERN CREECH
CAN HAVE THEM. ONLY MAN CAN GET
A VISION INSPIRATION TO LIFT
HIM ABOVE THE LEVEL OF HIMSELF.
AND SEND HIM FOURTH AGAINST ALL
OPPOSITION AND DISCOURAGE BUT-
TO DO AND TO DARE AND
ACCOMPLISHED WONDERFUL A GREAT
THING FOR THE WORLD FOR
HUMANITY. SO UNDERSTAND WHICH
WE HONOR MARTIN LUTHER KING I
JUST WANTED KNOWLEDGE. THAT HE
EXEMPLIFIES THIS VISION THAT
WAS STATED BY MATTHEW HENSON.
ANOTHER PATHFINDER IN AMERICAN
HISTORY. ACTUALLY AND I ALSO
WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT. A
SHORT TIME LATER IN CHICAGO IN
NINETEEN OH THREE. JANE ADDAMS
WHO FOUNDED A GREAT ENTERPRISE
IN CHICAGO TO SERVE THE NEEDY
AND ARRIVING IMMIGRANTS. HAS
SOMETHING TO SAY ABOUT THE
QUALITIES OF OUTSTANDING
AMERICAN LEADERSHIP AND AGAIN
SHE NEVER KNEW MARTIN LUTHER
KING. BUT LISTEN TO THIS IS A
CHARACTERIZATION OF. OF WHAT
OUR HISTORY NEEDS EVERY AUTUMN
MARTIN TODAY. WHAT IS A GREAT
MAN WHO HAS MADE HIS MARK IN
HISTORY. EVERY TIME IF WE THINK
FAR ENOUGH. HE IS A MAN WHO WAS
LOOK TO THE CONFUSION OF THE
MOMENT. AND IS SEEN THE MORAL
ISSUE INVOLVED. HE IS A MAN WHO
HAS REFUSED TO HAVE A SENSE OF
JUSTICE DISTORTED. HE HAS
LISTENED TO HIS CONSCIENCE
UNTIL CONSCIENCE BECOMES A
TRUMPET CALL TO LIKE MINDED MAN.
SO THAT THEY GATHER ABOUT HIM
AND TOGETHER WITH MUTUAL
PURPOSE OF MUTUAL AID THEY MAKE
A NEW PERIOD OF HISTORY. I WANT
OF KNOWLEDGE OF COURSE THAT
THESE ARE FROM THE FIRST DECADE
OF THE NINETEEN HUNDREDS SO
IT'S A LITTLE FOUR DOOR HERE
HERE MAN THIS MAN THAT. COURSE
WOULD MEAN PEOPLE. AND MARTIN
LUTHER KING WHICH CERTAINLY
UNDERSTAND THAT BUT I JUST. I'M
SO GRATEFUL ON BEHALF OF ALL OF
US FOR MY. GRAND DAUGHTER ANNA.
THE WE LIVE IN THIS NATION WE
HAVE PEOPLE SUCH VISION AND
WHAT A GREAT DAY TO HONOR
AMERICAN VISIONARY. THANK YOU
MISTER COOLEY SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER DOCTOR WEBER YOU MAY
CLOSE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
I WANT TO THANK MY COLLEAGUES
FROM THE VARIOUS CAUCUSES FOR
THEIR COMMENTS CONCERNING
DOCTOR KING. AND HIS
SIGNIFICANCE TO US. YOU KNOW
I'VE HAD THE GOOD FORTUNE I
THINK- TO LIVE LONG ENOUGH. TO
REMEMBER DCTOR KING. AT
ACTUALLY REMEMBER SEEING THE
MARCHES ON TELEVISION LIVE
SAYING THERE YOU ARE MARCH ON
WASHINGTON SEEING THE SELMA
INCIDENTS SAYING THOUGH IT
WATER HOLES TURNED ON
INDIVIDUALS AND THE DOGS TURNED
ON THEM. I'VE ALSO HAD THE GOOD
FORTUNE OF. GOING TO THE SOUTH
OF DURING THE ERA IN THE
NINETEEN FIFTIES AND SIXTIES.
AND BE AND SEEING THE KIND OF
DISCRIMINATION THAT EXISTED.
AND THE FEAR AND THE DIFFICULTY
OF PEOPLE TRYING TO LIVE JUST
ORDINARY LIVES EVERY DAY. AND
THEN I HAD THE UNFORTUNATE
EXPERIENCE OF ACTUALLY BEING
HERE WHEN DOCTOR KING WAS
ASSASSINATED I WAS AT UCLA. AND
WATCHING WHAT WAS HAPPENING ON
TELEVISION. AND HAVING THE
FEELING OF LOSS AND ABANDONMENT
THAT OCCURRED FROM MY STUDENTS.
WE COULD NOT BELIEVE THAT
SOMEONE FILLED WITH PEACE WOULD
BE TAKEN OUT IN SUCH A VIOLENT
MANNER. AND WE HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO FEEL A SENSE OF
LOSS IN THE MIDST OF. AN ERA
THAT WE THOUGHT WAS FILLED WITH
HOPE. SO IT'S INTERESTING AS WE
TALK ABOUT THIS AND DR KING'S
LEGACY COMES FORTH. WE HAD
YESTERDAY MR MCCARTY SELLERS
WHOSE FATHER WAS WHAT WHAT PART
OF THE CIVIL RIGHTS MOVEMENT.
TALK IN PERSONAL TERMS BECAUSE
SOMETIMES WE CAN GET CAUGHT UP
IN THE SPEECHES AND THE
STATEMENT THAT PEOPLE MAKE. AND
WE LOSE SIGHT OF THE PERSONAL
COMMITMENT. AND THE PERSONAL
LOSS THAT SO MANY INDIVIDUALS
SUFFERED IN THIS COUNTRY BLACK
WHITE JEWISH INDIVIDUALS WHO
BASICALLY WERE KILLED WHEN THE
CIVIL RIGHTS ERA STANDING UP
FOR JUST SIMPLE THINGS. LIKE TO
WRITE TO BE ABLE TO VOTE OR TO
MARY WHO YOU WANT WHAT TO DO
THE THINGS THAT WE TAKE SO MUCH
FOR GRANTED. AND SO I'VE BEEN
FORTUNATE TO HAVE THIS
EXPERIENCE OF AS A PART OF MY
LIFE THAT IS A DRIVING FORCE.
ABOUT THE SENSE OF URGENCY IN
HOW LONG DOES IT TAKE TO
ACHIEVE THE KIND OF JUSTICES
THAT BEARD. I ALSO HAVE THE
UNFORTUNATE FEELING AT THIS
POINT THAT AS WE MOVE FORWARD
IN THIS IN THIS IN THE TWENTY
TWENTY. THAT I'M WOULD BEING
PULLED BACK INTO AN ERA. THAT
WE DON'T WANT TO EVER GO BACK
TO AGAIN. THE HATRED. THE
DISCRIMINATION THE BURNING THE
SHOOTINGS THE THINGS THAT ARE
BASED ON RACE AND GENDER AND
RELIGION THAT IS SO UNFORTUNATE
THAT MARRED THIS COUNTRY. THAT
MARRED THIS COUNTRY AND MADE A
MAN HAVE TO GIVE HIS IN HIS
LIFE FOR US. TO BASICALLY
REMEMBER THAT THIS SHOULD NEVER
HAPPEN AGAIN. AND SO I FEEL A
SIN SO IT'S INTERESTING AS I
STAND HERE ON THIS FLOOR-
HAVING BEEN A PERSON WHO WILL
BE OBSERVED IT. AND FELT IT AND
THEN STUDIED IT AS A STUDENT AT
UCLA IN MY DOCTORAL WORK TO
LOOK AT THE VARIOUS MOVEMENTS
THAT OCCURRED IN THIS COUNTRY.
AND TO KNOW HOW MUCH SACRIFICE
THAT PEOPLE PUT INTO MAKING
SMALL PROGRESS. AND I SAY THAT
BECAUSE AS WE SIT HERE AND
WE'VE ALL BENEFITTED FROM
DOCTOR KING'S PRESENCE WHETHER
IT'S BEING ELECTED TO OFFICE
AND HAVING COMMUNITIES TO
EMBRACE US- THAT NORMALLY WOULD
NOT HAVE EMBRACED US. WE HAVE A
TREMENDOUS TREMENDOUS
RESPONSIBILITY. TO FIGHT. EIGHT
TO NOT LOSE SIGHT. TO BECOME
INDIGNANT A- DISCRIMINATION AND
RACISM AND SEXISM WE HAVE WE
HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY TO SHARE
THIS ACROSS THE BOARD. THAT IS
WHY IT IS SO IMPORTANT WHEN WE
TALK ABOUT CELEBRATING
INDIVIDUALS AND WHAT IT MEANS
TO CELEBRATE. IF THERE HAD BEEN
NO MARTIN LUTHER KING DAY. IF
THERE HAD BEEN NO A NATIONAL
CELEBRATION. WE PROBABLY WOULD
FORGET ABOUT KING. WE PROBABLY
WOULD LOSE OUR SENSIBILITIES TO
THE KIDS OF ISSUES THAT HE
RAISED. BUT FORTUNATELY HAVING
A NATIONAL HOLIDAY A STATE
HOLIDAY IN A NATIONAL HOLIDAY.
BRINGS US BACK TOGETHER EVERY
YEAR. TO REMIND US HOW
FORTUNATE WE ARE. BUT MOST
IMPORTANTLY TO REMIND US OF THE
DEBT THAT WE HAVE TO PAY. THAT
IT'S NOT REALLY ABOUT US BUT
IT'S ABOUT THIS NATION IN THE
FUTURE THAT'S THE YEAR. AND AS
THIS NATION TEETERS ON ALL OF
THESE CRITICAL ISSUES THAT WE
WILL SEE THIS WEEKEND. THE
MARCH IS A IN IN VIRGINIA WITH
NOW THERE MAY BE VERY VOLATILE
BECAUSE- FOLKS OF FIGHTING EACH
OTHER. OVER THE PRINCIPLES THAT
WE THINK ARE EMBEDDED IN THIS
NATION. WE HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY AS A LEGISLATOR
WE HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY AS
CITIZENS. WE HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY JUST AS HUMAN
BEINGS WHO WANT A BETTER WORLD
FOR OURSELVES AND OUR CHILDREN.
I WAS READING THE OTHER DAY THE
THOSE THE SPEECH THAT KING GAVE
WHEN HE RECEIVED THE NOBEL
PEACE PRIZE. ANY TALK ABOUT ALL
THE THINGS HE REFUSED TO
ACCEPT. HE SAID HE HE REFUSED
TO ACCEPT THAT WE ARE
POWERLESS. HE REFUSED TO ACCEPT
THAT THE NORMAL VIOLENCE AND
MILITARISM IS A WAY OF LIFE. HE
REFUSED TO ACCEPT THOSE THINGS
BUT HE ALSO SAID HE HAD AN
ABIDING FAITH. IN THE ABILITY
OF MAN TO RESURRECT HIMSELF IF
FROM THE MIDST OF ALL OF THIS.
AND TO FIGHT FOR JUSTICE AND
THAT EVEN IF WE LOSE ONE OF THE
BATTLES TO THE EVIL FORCES. IN
THE END WE WILL RISE AND WIN.
AND SO I CALL UPON YOU TODAY TO
AS WE HONOR DOCTOR KING. AN
HONOR THIS PARTICULAR OF AC
ARE. ALL ON THIS ACR ONE FORTY
SIX ON THIS FLOOR. THAT WE
DON'T LOSE SIGHT OF WHY WE'RE
HERE. THAT WE HAVE A DEBT TO
PAY. AND IT'S STILL THIS NATION
IS TO OUR CHILDREN AND OUR
FAMILIES. AND THAT AS WE FACE
WHAT WE THINK IS SUCH A
HORRIBLE REALITIES RIGHT NOW.
THAT WE CANNOT LOSE SIGHT OF
THE WE HAVE THE ABILITY WE HAVE
THE POWER. IF WE HAVE THE
COURAGE TO STAND UP AND MAKE
SURE THAT THE PRINCIPLES HE
FOUGHT FOR THAT WERE AMERICAN
PRINCIPLES. BUT WE WOULD MAKE
SURE THAT THEY LAY OF NOT JUST
THE AT THIS MOMENT BUT BASIC
LIVE IN CALIFORNIA. AFTER WEBER
WOULD YOU LIKE THE ROLE TO BE
OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS. THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE FOR. THIS IS
FOR CO AUTHORS. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE THIS IS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE THIS IS
FOR CO AUTHORS. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED IS THERE TO VOTE. CLERK
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY
VOTE THERE ARE SEVENTY ONE CO
AUTHORS ON EASIER ONE FORTY SIX
pA VOICE VOTE ON THE RESOLUTION.
ALL IN FAVOR SAY AYE. ALL
OPPOSED SAY NO THE AYES HAVE IT
THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
WE'LL PASS RETAIN A FILE ITEMS
ONE THIRTY THREE ONE THIRTY
SEVEN MOVING TO A VOTE ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR FILE ITEM ONE
THIRTY EIGHT DOES ANY MEMBER
WISH TO REMOVE AN ITEM FROM THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. SEEING AND
HEARING ON THE CLERK WILL READ
THE SECOND A CONSENT CALENDAR.
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE FORTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER AND
ACTUALLY TO HIGH SPEED RAIL.
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE IN
THE CONSENT COUNTY. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED VERY VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED IS THERE TO VOTE. ON
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
WHERE WELL CLOSE THE ROLE AND
TALLY THE VOTES. I SEC- I
SEVENTY NO ZERO. CAN THANK
COUNTIES ADOPTED THE CLERK WILL
READ THE REMAINING ITEMS ON THE
CONSENT THAT IS THE ONLY ITEM
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR. MOVING
TO ANNOUNCEMENTS MEMBERS HEALTH
COMMITTEE WILL BE MEETING UPON
INTERNMENT. OBSESSION IN ROOM
FORTY TWO OH TO THE SESSION
SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS MONDAY
JANUARY TWENTIETH IS A HOLIDAY
FOR MARTIN LUTHER KING JUNIOR
DAY. TUESDAY JANUARY TWENTY
FIRST WE ARE BACK IN SESSION AT
ONE PM. IN THE ABSENCE OF AN
OBJECTION THE QUORUM CALL IS
LIFTED AND WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY. MEMBERS
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS OR TAKE
YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF THE
FLOOR
. MEMBERS QUORUM CALL IS
LIFTED PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
OR TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF
THE FLOOR
. THANK YOU MEMBERS
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS FOR
GERMANY'S MEMORY GIVE YOU
RESPECTFUL ATTENTION TO OUR
COLLEAGUES. THE FOLLOWING
MEMBERS WERE GRANTED PRIOR
PERMISSION TO SPEAK. ON A NEW
GERMAN IN MEMORY. MR JOHNSON
WHERE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR GERMAN. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER ARE ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER- DONALD AND
MYSELF. I WOULD LIKE TO ASK
THAT WE ADJOURN THE MEMORY OF
ORAL PAYSINGER. OR WAS BORN IN
THE SUMMER OF NINETEEN FIFTY
FIVE. AND LIVED IN THE CITY OF
LONG BEACH HE GREW UP IN A
CARING HOME WITH TWO LOVING
PARENTS AND WAS THE YOUNGEST OF
SIX SIBLINGS. IN HIGH SCHOOL HE
EXCELLED IN SPORTSAND
ACADEMICS AND GRADUATED WITH
HONORS FROM NARBONNE HIGH
SCHOOL IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
FIVE. HE MET HIS WIFE MIGUEL.
GARCIA THE COOL WHILE ATTENDING
CHURCH THE HAPPY COUPLE HAD A
FRUITFUL MERITS OF FORTY YEARS.
DURING WHICH THEY WERE BLESSED
WITH TWO SONS STEVE AND BRIAN.
IN THE FALL OF NINETEEN SEVENTY
SIX- BEGAN HIS CAREER WITH THE
LOS ANGELES POLICE DEPARTMENT
OVER THE COURSE OF FOUR DECADES
HIS WORK ETHIC AND DEDICATION
LED HIM TO MOVE UP THROUGH THE
RANKS. FROM PATROL OFFICER TO
FIRST ASSISTANT CHIEF THE
SECOND HIGHEST RANKING POST IN
THE DEPARTMENT. AS ONE OF LA
PT'S HIGHEST PROFILE BLACK
LEADERS- ADVOCATED FOR TO
DIVERT DIVERSIFICATION OF THE
FORCE AND HELP EASE TO FRICTION
BETWEEN OFFICERS AND CITY
RESIDENTS. PARTICULARLY IN
SOUTH LOS ANGELES MY DISTRICT-
ALSO SERVED AS A MENTOR TO
THOUSANDS OF KIDS THROUGH THE
LAPD DEBT LEADERSHIP PROGRAM.
IN TWENTY SIXTEEN AFTER FORTY
YEARS OF SERVICE HE RETIRED
FROM THE LOS ANGELES POLICE
DEPARTMENT AND TOOK A POSITION
AT THE UNIVERSITY. OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AS THE VICE
PRESIDENT BEEN OF CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT. AT USC- WORK TO
STRENGTHEN COMMUNITY OUTREACH
AND IMPROVE INVOLVEMENT IN THE
NEIGHBORHOOD SURROUNDING THE
CAMPUS HE ALSO TACKLE
HOMELESSNESS ISSUES WHILE
WORKING TO ELEVATE SOUTH CENTER
LOS RESIDENTES SOCIAL. PHYSICAL
AND ECONOMIC WELL BEING THROUGH
HIS LEADERSHIP AND THE SERVICE-
MADE THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES A
BETTER. FOR ALL OF US. HE IS
SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE TWO SONS
HIS HIS POPULAR. HIS SIBLINGS
AS WELL AS MANY FRIENDS. WILL
BE SUPER EARLY TOTALLY MESS.
BIRDS ARE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
WHICH AREN'T IN THE MEMORY OF
EARL PAYSINGER. THANK YOU
MISTER JONES SAWYER MISTER
SALAS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR GERMAN MEMORY. THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER- TODAY RISE TO
JOURNAL THE MEMORY OF CORPORATE
CITY COUNCILMEN RAMEN LARAMIDE-
HE IS A MAN WHO WEARS MANY HATS
IN WHO HAD THE BEST INTERESTS
OF THE COMMUNITY IN MIND IS THE
BEST WAY TO DESCRIBE CORCORAN
CITY COUNCILMAN. RAMEN ALARMA
IN ADDITION TO ACT. TO BEING A
COUNCILMAN RAISE A SON HUSBAND
FATHER GRANDFATHER EDUCATOR
ACTIVIST WRITER IN ADVISER WHO
SERVED ON THE CORPORATE CITY-COUNCIL FOR TWENTY FIVE YEARS
HAVING FIRST BEEN ELECTED IN
NINETEEN NINETY FOUR. HE
STARTED HIS ADVOCACY FOR THE
RESIDENTS OF CORCORAN AFTER HE
HIMSELF HAD AN ISSUE WITH CITY
GOVERNMENT. MR LEVEL WAS A
MEMBER OF A BIG FAMILY RAY WAS
ONE OF NINE CHILDREN BORN TO
CRUISE AND DORIAL LETTER MY-
HIS MOM IS NINETY YEARS OLD AND
HIS FATHER PASSED AWAY IN
NINETEEN NINETY FOUR. RAISING A
BIG FAMILY WAS HARD HE SAID BUT
THEY ALL WORKED WHEN THEY COULD
HE REMEMBERS MIGRATING UP AND
DOWN THE STATE PICKING
POTATOES. AND WASCO AND CHAPTER
PRUNES IN VACAVILLE
STRAWBERRIES. IN OREGON AND
ORANGES IN THE FOOTHILLS. RAY
BECAME A TEACHER AND THE
SIBLINGS AND THE SIBLINGS HAVE
WORKED AS A COUNSELOR TEACHER
LEARNING DIRECTOR HOSPITAL
ADMINISTRATOR IN PEACE OFFICERS
MOST GRADUATED FROM UNIVERSITY
AND EDUCATION HAS BEEN A BIG
PART OF THE LEARN A FAMILY FACT
YOU WOULD ALWAYS HERE MISTER
LERMA SAY GO BEARS AS HE WAS A
GRADUATE. FROM UC BERKELEY. RAY
IS FAT AND HIS WIFE OF ALMOST
FORTY THREE YEARS LOW WHO'S A
RETIRED TEACHER OF THREE
CHILDREN. ALFA RAMON AND PABLO
WHO ALSO BECAME TEACHERS. RAY
RETIRED FROM TEACHING- FROM
CORPORATE UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT. FOUR YEARS AGO AFTER
THIRTY EIGHT YEARS IN THE
CLASSROOM AT CORPORATE HIGH. HE
RETIRED BUT YOU COULD STILL
FIND THEM AT THE HEAD OF A
CLASS. AS HE TAUGHT IN ESL
CLASS FOR ADULTS STUDENTS HE
WAS A PART TIME PROFESSOR FOR
THE COLLEGE OF THE SEQUOIAS. HE
ALSO TOLD TAUGHT ADULT
EDUCATION CLASSES AT AT
CORCORAN UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT HE SAYS THE CONNECTION
WITH CORPORATE HEISTS SCHOOL
STUDENTS AS THE VOLUNTEERS AS A
MATCH ADVISER CLUB. I THIS KEEP
THEM BUSY HE'S ALWAYS INVOLVED
WITH THE KIDS- MEMBERS YOU MAY
REMEMBER CELEBRITIES HE
ACTUALLY USED TO COME UP HERE.
HE WAS ACTUALLY VERY
INSTRUMENTAL IN A BUDGET ITEM.
THAT WE WERE ADVOCATING FOR THE
LAST COUPLE OF YEARS OF THIS
HOUSE ACTUALLY PASSED. AND SAW
WHAT I CAN TELL YOU IS MISTER
LARA IS A PERSONAL FRIEND I USE
ONE OF THESE INDIVIDUALS I JUST
HAD A HEART FOR THE COMMUNITY.
YOU SAW THAT FOR OF HOW WE GOT
INVOLVED. RIGHT LIKE ORDINARY
CITIZEN HE HAD AN ISSUE WITH.
WITH THE CITY. AND NOT ONLY DID
HE RESOLVE IT HE SAID YOU KNOW
WHATI NEED TO DO SOMETHING
MORE FOR MY COMMUNITY AND
THAT'S WHEN HE FIRST RAN FOR
ELECTED OFFICE. BUT HE DIDN'T
LET THAT TO STOP I'M JUST
SERVING ON THE CITY COUNCIL HE
WENT OUT THE KIDS. RIGHT HE DID
THAT FOR THIRTY EIGHT YEARS
AND- IN THE CLASSROOM. AND THEN
WHEN HIS TIME WAS UP IT SAYS
HAVE RETIRED I'M STILL NOT
DEAD. HE STILL FOUND A WAY TO
GO BACK. BE A MENTOR FOR THE
CHILDREN IN THE COMMUNITY HE
STILL WENT BACK TO THE LOCAL
COMMUNITY COLLEGE. HE'S JUST
ONE OF THESE INDIVIDUALS THAT
HAD A HEART. A HEART OF GOLD A
HEART. TO CONTINUE TO CAN. TO
CONTINUE TO DO FOR HIS
COMMUNITY AND THAT'S WHAT I
LOVED ABOUT MISTER LARA.
BECAUSE HE WOULD JUST CALL ME
WOULD TEXT ME WOULD SAY HEY. WE
NEED TO DO ONE MORE THING. IT
WAS ALWAYS ONE MORE THING THAT
WE COULD DO FOR THAT COMMUNITY.
AND SO WHEN WE- DID THE BUDGET
ALLOCATION FOR THE CITY OF
QUIRK READ- I HAVE TO SAY. MR
LARA WAS INSTRUMENTAL IN THAT.
AND SO. UP I RESPECTFULLY ASK
OF THIS HOUSE ADJOURN IN HIS
MEMORY. HE IS A FRIEND THAT
WILL BE- SORELY MISSED AND- AND
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
TURN HIS MEMORY. THANK YOU
MISTER SALAS AND GO BEARS. MR
GABRIEL YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR GERMAN MEMORY. THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER I RISE TODAY TO
REQUEST THAT WE ARE JOINED IN
MEMORY OF HEAVY ORDEN WHO
PASSED AWAY EARLIER THIS WEEK.
AT THE AGE OF NINETY THREE. HAD
HE LIVED A REMARKABLE LIFE THAT
EXEMPLIFIED THE POWER OF LOVE
TO HELP HEAL DEEPEST OF PAIN.
BORN INTO A PROMINENT JEWISH
AND SINUS FAMILY AND RETIRED
ROMANIA SHE WAS JUST EIGHTEEN
YEARS OLD WHEN THE **** INVADED
IN NINETEEN FORTY FOUR. WITHIN
WEEKS HAVY AND HER FAMILY WERE
FORCED INTO A GHETTO AND THEN
SHIPPED BY CATTLE CARS TO
AUSCHWITZ. MUCH OF HER FAMILY
WAS KILLED IMMEDIATELY BUT
HEAVY AND HER MOTHER DEFIED ALL
ODDS TO SURVIVE. TRAGICALLY
HEAVIES MOTHER PASSED AWAY JUST
FIVE DAYS AFTER THEIR
LIBERATION IN MAY OF NINETEEN
FORTY FIVE BUT SHE REMAINED A
GUIDING LIGHT TO HEAVY
THROUGHOUT HER LIFE. AFTER THE
WAR HAD HE RETURNED TO ROMANIA
AND WITHIN A FEW MONTHS SHE MET
HER BELOVED TAD WHO PROPOSED TO
HER AFTER ONLY THIRTY MINUTES.
WHILE SHE DECLINED HIS INITIAL
PROPOSAL THE COUPLE MARRIED SIX
MONTHS LATER AND SHARED LIFE
FOR THE NEXT SIXTY NINE YEARS.
TOGETHER THEY RAISED THREE
DAUGHTERS AND ESTABLISHED A
LARGE AND LOVING EXTENDED A
FAMILY THAT INCLUDES MY CLOSE
FRIEND AND A GREAT LEADER IN
THE LOS ANGELES JEWISH
COMMUNITY BRIAN BURR CAT. WHO
BECAME ENGAGED ONLY SHORTLY
BEFORE HAD HE PASSED. IN
NINETEEN FIFTY EIGHT TED AND
HEAVY AND THEIR THEN TWO
DAUGHTERS- SEIZED AN
OPPORTUNITY TO ESCAPE FROM
COMMUNIST ROMANIA ND
EVENTUALLY IMMIGRATED TO THE
UNITED STATES. HEAVY BEGAN
WORKING JUST TEN DAYS AFTER HER
ARRIVAL IN LOS ANGELES AND IN
NINETEEN SIXTY THE COUPLE
OPENED A MODEST SERVICE STATION
IN BELLFLOWER CALIFORNIA. IT
WAS THE FIRST OUT- SO BUSINESS
THAT WOULD EVENTUALLY GROW TO
BECOME THE LARGEST PRIVATE.
INDEPENDENT OWNER AND OPERATOR
OF SERVICE STATIONS ON THE WEST
COAST OF THE UNITED STATES. TED
IN HAITI WERE FOREVER GRATEFUL
TO THE UNITED STATES AND USE
THEIR SUCCESS TO BENEFIT THE
COMMUNITY. AMONG OTHER
INVOLVEMENT THEY GENEROUSLY
SUPPORTED NUMEROUS
PHILANTHROPIC AND CHARITABLE
ORGANIZATIONS INCLUDING CEDAR
SINAI MEDICAL CENTER. THE LA
OPERA THE MUSIC CENTER THE
JEWISH FEDERATION OF GREATER
LOS ANGELES SINAI TEMPLE THE
JEWISH NATIONAL FUND IN A PACK.
HEAVY ALSO ANY PARTICULAR SOME
PASSION FOR SUPPORTING AGING
HOLLIS COST SURVIVORS AND
INCREASING EDUCATION AND
AWARENESS ABOUT THE SHOW ARE.
SHE ALSO DERIVED GREAT JOY FROM
THE MANY YOUNG PEOPLE WHO MET
THEIR FUTURE SPOUSES AT THE TED
AND HEAVY ORDEN FRIDAY NIGHT
LIFE PROGRAM AT SINAI TEMPLE.
AS HER DAUGHTER MARTHA
REFLECTED AT THE FUNERAL HEAVY
DEFINED TO GRACE STEADFASTNESS
KOREJE EMPATHY AND KINDNESS.
AND SHE VIEWED THE YEARS AFTER
SURVIVING THE HOLOCAUST IT'S A
GIFT THAT SHE NEVER TOOK FOR
GRANTED. A FAMOUS JEWISH
ETHICAL TEACHING KNOWN AS PER
CALVO TEACHES YOU ARE NOT
OBLIGATED TO COMPLETE THE WORK
BUT NEITHER ARE YOU FREE TO
DESIST TO DESIST FROM IT. HAD A
HEAVY ORDEN PER MARK A LIFE
ROUGHLY WISDOM AND HER LEGACY
IS A LARGE LOVING AND DEEPLY
COMMITTED FAMILY THAT IS
COMMITTED TO CARRYING ON HER
WORK. HAD HE WILL BE DEEPLY
MISSED BUT HER MEMORY WILL BE A
BLESSING FOR CALIFORNIA FOR
ISRAEL IN FOR A JEWISH
COMMUNITY. I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST THAT WE ADJOURN TODAY
IN HER MEMORY. THANK YOU MR
GABRIEL MISTER BLOOM YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED ON THIS GERMAN
MEMORY THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER-%
I JOIN IN. ASKING THAT WE ARE
ADJOURNED IN MEMORY OF HEAVY
ORTON AND- THE MEMBER FROM US
AND GAVE US SAN FERNANDO VALLEY.
ASKED ME IF HE COULD DO THIS
ADJOURNMENT BECAUSE HE'S A
PERSONAL FRIEND OF THE FAMILY
WHO HAPPEN TO LIVE IN MY
DISTRICT IN THE SIMPLE THING
THAT I WANT TO ADD TO THE VERY
ELOQUENT ADJOURNMENT IN MEMORY.
THAT TO. OUT OF THAT HE JUST
GAVE IS. HOW REMARKABLE IT IS
THAT THIS THE HUMAN SPIRIT
COULD BE SO RESILIENT- AND IN
IN TRUTH HEAVY ORTON IS NOT THE
ONLY INDIVIDUAL WHO SURVIVED
THE DEATH CAMPS OF GERMANY AND-
WENT ON TO LIVE A FULFILLING A
AND VALUABLE LIFE. A LIFE THAT
ADDED TO HER FAMILY THAT ADDED
TO HER COMMUNITY- THIS STORY IS
REPEATED OVER AND OVER AND OVER
AGAIN FOLLOWING THE ASHES OF
THE HOLOCAUST. AND SO AS WE
ADJOURN IN HER MEMORY I WANT TO
ASK YOU TO THINK ABOUT HER AB
OF HEAVY ORDEN AS A SYMBOL OF
WHAT CAN BE AND HOW RESILIENT
THE HUMAN SPIRIT CAN BE. SIR
BLOOM. MISTER GIBSON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN
MEMORY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM SPEAKER IN MEMBERS I RISE
**** BODY TO ADJOURN IN THE
MEMORY OF DAISY IN MCKINNEY-
SHE WAS A VIVACIOUS WOMAN WHO
WATCH ME GROW UP THIS AS I
WATCHED HER CHILDREN- GROW UP-
IN THE CHURCH HELLO CHURCH ON
THE SIDE OF THE ROAD LOS
ANGELES CALLED PENA WELL
MISSIONARY BAPTIST CHURCH. SHE
WAS AN ORDINARY WOMAN WHO DID
EXTRAORDINARY THINGS SO HR
LIFE EXEMPLIFIED THE EGGS THE
EXTRAORDINARY THINGS THAT SHE
WOULD DO FOR THE COMMUNITY SHE
RETIRED FROM THE CITY OF
COMPTON- BY GIVING ALMOST
THIRTY YEARS OF HER LIFE TO THE
RESIDENTS OF THE CITY OF
COMPTON THIS ORDINARY
EXTRAORDINARY WOMAN- GREW UP IN
LOUISIANA. SHE WAS ONE OF
SEVENTEEN CHILDREN- AND I'M
SEVENTEEN CHILDREN HER MOTHER
DIED NINE MONTHS AGO AND SHE
DIED OF CANCER- FIVE MONTHS OR
SIX MONTHS RIGHT AFTER HER
MOTHER PASSED AWAY SHE LEAVE
BEHIND IT SHARES HER MEMORY-
THREE CHILDREN WHOSE CERTAINLY
I WILL CONTINUE HER LEGACY
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT
YOU ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF MY
GOOD FRIEND WHO WATCHED ME GROW
UP IN CHURCH- DAISY M. KENNY
THANK YOU MISTER GIPSON MEMBERS
PLEASE BRING THE NAMES TO THE
DESK TO BE PRINTED IN THE
JOURNAL OUR QUEST TO JOURNEY
MEMORY WILL BE DEEMED READ. IN
THE JOURNAL ALL OTHER ITEMS
REMAINING WOULD HAPPEN TAKE
INTO ALL MOTION SHALL BE
CONTINUED SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER BUSINESS I'M READY TO
ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO ADJOURN
MISTER GIBSON MOVES IN MISTER
KALRA SECONDS THAT THIS HOUSE
STANDS ADJOURNED UNTIL TO. DAY
JANUARY TWENTY FIRST AT ONE PM